salud en directo américa de france 24 me
acompaña en el estudio marina sardina
marina bienvenida buena mañana de martes
hoy se celebra el día mundial de los
alimentos y no cos le pregunto qué
quiere decir esto marina buenos días
raúl pues la inocuidad de los alimentos
puede definirse como el conjunto de
condiciones y medidas necesarias durante
la producción el almacenamiento o la
distribución y preparación de estos
alimentos para asegurarse que una vez
ingeridos no representan un daño o un
riesgo para la salud la gravedad de este
impacto de estas enfermedades derivadas
de alimentos insalubres pues han
cambiado y variado a lo largo del tiempo
pues como también han cambiado el tipo
de alimentos y la forma en la que los
consumimos por ejemplo también las
enfermedades que se transmiten por los
alimentos son una de las causas más
importantes de morbilidad y mortalidad
en todo el mundo desde que muchas veces
hay un subregistro de estos decesos pese
a esto veamos también que dijo la oms en
este día de la y el de la inocuidad de
los alimentos
woods safety y se las enfermedades
transmitidas por los alimentos son una
problemática de salud que no siempre es
considerada por los estados por los
países por los sistemas de salud de
confesión
necesitamos concientizar sobre esto no
es sólo una problemática de los
gobiernos también las industrias
alimentarias y la sociedad civil
incluyendo los consumidores para que
conozcan más sobre este problema
consumers unión mor roig decisión marina
le pregunté entonces qué puede ocurrir
si una persona pasa toda tu toda su vida
ingiriendo alimentos en mal estado
esto se puede considerar un tema de
salud pública por supuesto es un tema de
salud pública que genera altísimos
costos a los sistemas sanitarios y a los
estados cada año se pierden 110 mil
millones de dólares en gastos médicos
generados por alimentos insalubres por
estas enfermedades en países de bajos y
medios recursos veamos en la siguiente
gráfica algunos datos los alimentos
nocivos o inseguros que contienen
bacterias virus parásitos o sustancias
que son dañinas muchas veces generadas
por los fertilizantes que se emplean en
la agricultura pueden causar la muerte
las más de 200 enfermedades por su
ingesta dolencias que van desde la
diarrea hasta enfermedades crónicas que
aparecen mucho tiempo después o cáncer
se estima que cada año 600 millones de
personas en el mundo
o sea una de cada 10 personas se
enferman por alimentos contaminados
esto representa también 420 mil personas
que mueren cada año por esta ingesta
especialmente en países del sur global
de ellos lastimosamente 125 mil son
menores de edad menores de 5 años que
junto con las mujeres embarazadas o los
ancianos pues son los grupos
poblacionales más vulnerables a este
tipo de enfermedad de raúl marina y le
pregunto cuál es entonces son las
enfermedades más comunes relacionadas
con esta inocuidad de los alimentos
generalmente son enfermedades de
carácter infeccioso o tóxico que
penetran en el organismo a través del
agua o alimentos contaminados aquí
también las organizaciones radio hacen
un énfasis en la necesidad de que el
acceso a agua potable para todo el mundo
para evitar este tipo de enfermedades
también a kelava y se producen al lavar
de alimento se estima que sólo una de
cada tres personas en el mundo tiene
acceso a agua potable por ejemplo
algunas de las dolencias más comunes
derivadas de estos alimentos nocivos son
la salmonela que es muy conocida la
listeria que provoca abortos espontáneos
o muerte neonatal o enfermedades
diarreicas que se provocan la muerte de
96 mil niños cada año especialmente esto
ocurre en países de áfrica de américa
latina' o de asia donde las
desigualdades pues son más patentes y
ese está estrechamente ligado con la
inseguridad alimentaria la insalubridad
de los alimentos ha generado un vínculo
vicioso de estas enfermedades con la
malnutrición dado que algunos patógenos
patógenos son transmitidos por alimentos
que aprovechan estos sistemas
inmunitarios débiles que derivan nuevo
en un mayor incremento de decesos marina
le preguntó entonces específicamente por
el panorama en nuestra región de américa
latina y el caribe donde la fuerte
desigualdad es que nuestra región afecte
especialmente a la salud de las personas
si en américa latina' o caribe los datos
de la fao es que 4 de cada 10
y experimentan inseguridad alimentaria
raúl grave o moderada esto según unas
cifras de 2020 fue un aumento de 9
puntos porcentuales también incrementado
pues con la pandemia como pasó en todo
el mundo pero además en américa latina
pues fue una de las regiones donde más
se incrementó este tipo en la región
americana latinoamericana y del caribe
como vemos en el gráfico se ve un fuerte
crecimiento de la inseguridad
alimentaria moderada o grave en 2014
había 153 millones de personas
padeciendo esto y en 2020 esta cifra
casi se duplica con 267 millones de
personas y es que pese a ser una región
agrícola como es toda la región
latinoamericana y una es una de las
zonas donde comer saludable es más
costoso por ello también muchas personas
muchas familias hacen a productos pues
procesados que no son tan saludables y
que generan otro tipo de enfermedades
pues como la obesidad o la diabetes por
ello también las organizaciones están
haciendo un pedido y un llamado a
consumir productos orgánicos también
apoyar a los pequeños campesinos y al
campesinado pues para acabar con las
desigualdades
ayudaría a erradicar también esta
inseguridad alimentaria marina
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información además este tema le da pie a
nuestro segundo invitado al día para
hablar precisamente esta inseguridad
alimentaria en nuestra región y también
en áfrica donde pues la cuestión de esta
seguridad alimentaria la verdad está muy
agravada por la guerra en ucrania
gracias marina pasamos entonces a
saludar a nuestro segundo imitado el día